what a wonderful III it was and one of
my favorite announcements and many of
yours was finally seeing some hot
fallout 4 nonsense it looks pretty great
it's coming out this year and it's got a
bunch of new features that we've been
asking for in the series for a long time
Justin hey Walt anja baman are here both
fans of the series and we're going to
talk about some other stuff that we'd
like to see in the game and coming up
later this year first of all though they
added a bunch of stuff that we already
got like they had a bunch of stuff that
we already wanted like better shooting
and stuff Justin what what did you think
about what they shou shou the fallout 4
I it's a loop it's everything you want I
mean it's one of those just big world
gates the reveal of it is itself just so
exciting uh even though we knew is going
to be in Boston like the the fact that
it opens up the those more possibilities
for like what are these people gonna be
like what's this world gonna be them
because even though it's still in
America it's still this post-apocalyptic
wasteland and like it's gonna be new
characters it's going to be like a whole
new setting a whole new basically a
world to explore and that's one of the
things that I think I'd really like to
see more of an fallout 4 is like we know
that they're all these different vaults
that they well they have all these
different experiments and one thing that
I think uh was obsidian with oblivion
that they did really well is every new
vegas person well with the the Oblivion
series is like i was talking to you
about this earlier is that you have all
this lauren things you're able to
explore and one of them are the books
like I love getting books and reading
through in like being immersed in this
world but I don't like actually doing it
on my TV screen so like I I downloaded
this kindle version of all of the books
in the game that's so good and I'd love
to be able to do something like that and
fallout like because there is so now
like it's an even more expanding
universe there's so much more going on
in the world like I love exploring that
outside of the game and when getting
that sent to me either my Kindle or my
phone yeah I like that because it's like
that does that put so much time into
crafting these worlds and having all
this text and it kind of doesn't really
feel like the right time to read it like
even I think the witcher at the moment i
did a bunch over the weekend and like
taking time to even read one of those
books as somebody who read some of the
books it's like a really nice little
past time and it doesn't feel like the
right place to do it so you wanted to be
a part of the game as well one
problem I think destiny has is that
almost all of that story is buried
outside of the game like you have to go
outside to even have a modicum of
understanding what's going on where is
the fallout games of the Oblivion games
there was at lowes always been contained
you know what's going on but they add
color they had a richness to the world
that makes it even more fun to explore
Andy one of the things that obviously
Justin touched upon obsidian there and
you're a big fan of a new vegas you know
one of the things you were talking about
before we went on was the the faction
element of that which i'd actually
completely forgot about that stuff
wasn't in for like three and in New
Vegas upsetting sort of played around
with that and had you picking which
faction for that crazy fight at the end
I actually only completed New Vegas
about two weeks ago finally I like
loaded up my savegame [ __ ] up the
Great Khans pretty bad and you'd like to
see that come on until fall out for ya
because the car systems always been in
file gives big huge like you know things
since the beginning but the faction
reputations came in and follow to then
they were kind of gone in fallout 3
they're back in New Vegas and you're
like yeah it gives you the opportunity
to do quests for those factions go
through those storylines get deeper into
the backstory of you know characters and
elements there which you know but this
is really strong at doing that because
they do it in Skyrim they do it in their
oblivion games where you do the black
hand missions and they're free conceived
as hell and they're awesome that's like
its own game you do the Thieves Guild
miss you want to do all the guild
missions and stuff because they're just
so rich and you get like rewarded you
get reputation you get new abilities and
armor sets yeah cuz lane this is all
this is all like kind of missing in
fallout 3 in a way it was I had your
main quest Nia had like the side quests
were actually rather small but there yet
I feel like the only like large ones
were like the Brotherhood of Steel right
and that was like a good faction one but
it also had like endgame it had like
game overall yeah tie-in so that you had
to do it but yet in New Vegas certainly
you could do like all the little
factions and depending on how far you've
gotten what you did like really affected
the outcome of the entire game but you
also got to know those storylines really
well so that that's something I think
they're missing I mean besides all the
other stuff they added any three were
like you know you've got the second
screen experience with good boy i got a
boy freaking crafting system the show
right now like yeah all this [ __ ] is is
already like we didn't
for this but is yes I really hot stuff
was like murmured I feel like yeah
increased crafting with something a lot
of people talked about I feel like that
and actual good first person shooting
right and like you're a massive new
vegas yes but it was always a problem it
was always a problem and New Vegas did
add aim down sights which make like cool
till I use some of the guns that you
could it kind of also like highlighted
how shitty those guns and it definitely
highlight how should it was and you get
the cinematic like kill cam and stuff
which was cool so I hope they bring all
that over honestly like I the list of
stuff I came up with this stuff they
added four new vegas that I hope they
carry over like the hardcore mode yes
where you have to sleep eat limb you
have to get your limbs repaired by
doctors yeah partially heal them like
it's not that hard it's not that hard I
ended up not being that bad in the grand
scheme like you can just sleep and eat
and it's all it's all good but it's but
it's kind of fun some stuff I think they
should add in the cooking stuff haven't
was in New Vegas new dog though yeah
they got all those so here's some things
go for it from the other games I think
they should bring back that I think a
lot of people will hate okay so the
first game had a hardcore time pressure
from the very first quest you had to
find the water ship or else your vault
was gonna die which is pretty awesome
actually cuz like you had to like get
off you had to roleplay it freakin do it
you had like a fire under your ass to go
this [ __ ] done yeah do you ever feel
that way in The Witcher where you're
kind of like yeah we're doing this I
should probably be helping me very
meditating like to get I'm merchant to
like replenisher gold stash and we like
what if series like dying out there and
likes because you're always like banging
doors I gonna say behind her but then
you're like i just spent like five days
on this werewolf cuesta college I just
like meditated for years like some ice
or for when I started out the witcher
likely when you get past that first area
I was like yeah you know I have stuff
going on but I guess I'm just gonna get
in a boat and sail over that same see
what's going on so like but the great
part about fall at one is you it was
like Act one was time pressure yeah but
then act 2 opened up and you could
actually do it it was pretty short in
the first version of the game you could
actually lose the game again by failing
the time the clock but in version like
1.1 they update it to be like 13 game
years before you actually don't worry
they had something cool like that where
I fell out for was like I don't know 50
game years and then you
box like that would be amazing a one
thing in Fallout to drug addiction
really uh well you couldn't you can get
addicted by creative in 3 i'm not sure
if you got addicted or if it just you
just range of effects yeah use it i
wanna bring back like jet usage because
like if you're in a fight in the early
game you had to like boost and you're
like all i have is jet oh god like there
we go and then you're like an addict and
you have to go through all this to get
to get out of it um yeah oh one thing
that does is great at that I hope and we
kind of don't know cool actors playing a
big role Oh meme Neeson Liam Neeson's as
the freaking dad in fallout 3 another I
Matthew Perry was in Vegas yeah he was a
massive whole night fan as well that's
why you're involved in the project I
wonder now because they financed the
voice actors I wonder how they oh [ __ ] I
think so yeah I saw some people on
Twitter said that's who they were but
they're kind of relatively unknown
actors in the in the area so you never
know maybe they've got a bigger voice
talent crew he gonna got it we need like
a secret one like a big candy I was
going Freeman yeah did Skyrim have like
a like a notable I don't know if it tell
you know dragon was played by [ __ ]
Patrick Stewart projects to know that
was oblivion penashue it oh you're right
oh god I totally forgot about that so
that's what I'm talking about hey that's
all you have to say about file for i
kind of think like it's just it's from
playing The Witcher i think is where I'd
like pulled a lot of them by like
inspiration I got really I'd love a
horse like wait oh dude we've already
seen I feel like horses and open world
games is almost like a one and done like
it kind of works we've seen the like
this massive airship we've seen the
vertibird zarnow pilot able and or at
least you can imagine them they will
drive you around yeah we don't know if
you're able to drive them yourself so
per I'd like imagine if you could
finally get cars working and there's
like the super weapon that maybe you aim
it stuff maybe or that's part of
question oh maybe that's just Megaton
yeah visited you know but the other
thing I kind of wouldn't mind from
fallout is that you I guess this is
probably just a byproduct of the fact
that New Vegas is now back in 2009 I
think it came out no God is that the
quests in that game Justin were there
was the main quest and then there was
like the side quest were kind of these
relatively small diversions like you
talked about going into the crazy little
fault son like it meeting somebody and
meeting up didn't really go on the thing
in which are is that I
side quests which ended in five minutes
and I've done side quests which have
gone on for like three hours that's sort
of variety that'll be like where you
don't really know what's the main quest
anymore I think would be really fun
though and that's something that fits i
think that fallout feeling more as well
that you are just kind of exploring this
waistline like there shouldn't be a
narrative like everyone's experience
should be different no matter when you
started when you when you finish playing
and like maybe you'll just feel like oh
I came to two for me that was a good
ending point like maybe I won't
necessarily find and solve every quest
and get every puzzle yeah I was just
exploring this world and that's what I
got out of it they've already added one
thing that I would have always wanted
which is an amazing dog well my aunts in
games they should have all those are in
three just wasn't Donna me yeah yeah he
could also die apparently this one can't
die 01 invincible dogs yeah because you
want dead dogs yeah dude the only reason
to get the dog in these games is to just
put your fat boy and like all of your
heavy weapon [ __ ] that you only have
used when some badness comes down and
just give it to Fox hey boy and then
when people just call him over and baby
like yeah okay hey boy let's trade yeah
trade was one about it yeah last thing
to add habita you can play once the game
is finished because they [ __ ] this twice
they had it in fallout 3 which they
patch to theirs yeah eventually but new
vegas was the same thing I compete at
New Vegas and it tells you the story of
the waistline then they're like and then
you're done use the credits Todd Howard
and go under hey all I mean the big
criticism of thought through was the
main line quest was kind of man yeah and
then like everything else was amazing so
yeah if they can figure they can pull
from The Witcher and just say like look
here's how you do freakin quests sure
like request structure 2015 Oh what if
they pull from the witch or something
like and went like that you have a
different universe all rights gonna be a
collectible card game it's also going to
be a part of its own app it's a
separately follow shelter if you tell me
that gwent is actually exactly the same
of all at four and all my stuff will
carry over I'm definitely
you